beaucoup de gens mais depuis longtemps
mais beaucoup maintenant il aux gens la
salle ils m'ont reconnu à l'accent je
suis contre la loi visant à protéger
ceux qui ont un accent je suis content
parce que je n'ai jamais eu le sentiment
que c'était un danger n'est pas en
danger comme a pu l'être en deux
couleurs en ab siècle je ne t'ai pas
engagé comme les fameux entêté depuis la
nuit des temps
je n'ai pas le sentiment que c'est
enlever quoique ce soit à la vie on a pu
l'associent à certains moments pour le
combattre mais bon le coma c'est le coma
si vous n'avez pas le combat il faut
surtout pas y aller il faut se défendre
et faut défendre son accent comme on
défend ses convictions
je pense que je suis pro républicain
pour me permettre de déranger la
république pour un fait aussi mineur
[Musique]
ceux servis en disant qu'ils avaient
porté préjudice de marcel pagnol de son
aide exceptionnelle avec ses hommes
raimu fernandel
moi j'aimerais bien des revoir dans ce
cinéma monocorde
coût de gens mais depuis longtemps mais
beaucoup maintenant il aux gens la salle
ils ont reconnu à l'accent ils sont de
paris sans de béthune qui avait tué
l'autre jour déjà libéré j'avais vu
qu'il entendait parler là le trait même
alors que je faisais là le courage de
bonner contre là où est ma place c'est
jean lassalle ces gens là c'est donc
qu'on me reconnais à ma voix dans la
voix que c'est quand même un film qui
fait chaud au coeur et on dit même des
fois que j'ai une voix agréable
alors pourquoi voulez vous voyez-vous
chronos plus tôt ça fait partie d'une
personnalité
[Musique]
oui parce que c'est pas
le débat que j'ai découvert que au fond
il y avait des accents dans l'est dans
l'eau reste dans le nord au sud partout
en france alors ne parlons pas de ce
beau de france merveille dans le
challenge ce n'est le dit qu'au fond il
n'y avait que trois arrondissements
qu'on lit souvent à paris qui était à
peu près dans des standards et codes
qu'est ce que vous en pensez vous
comment faire quand vous avez une telle
étendue de ce nul arrêté vers sa
revanche et toujours considéré que
c'était une chance